okay we're back and the reason I
abruptly left before wasn't because
lunch is ready and I was hungry both
because I may tell you very best is a
bet but it that's going on here
no they best out cliffhanger is a one
that just kind of ends on the middle
hood episode for an hour he said you
know okay so where are your hair again
yes tip an animal's yes step in a house
okay I'll - it's got out here and I do
this I did do this I think I was like to
the right okay leave him oh crap
I think I threw the chair last time I
hit the other guy on the head we sitting
like that
mmm-hmm
I'm just a baseball player it's like
what do you want me to down like I'm
just a base off liar
uh-huh fell out are you down over here
ages crawls in here to die I guess you
know that's what happens in EMS let that
past you die like the rest okay I can
remember that right trigger just like
gently drop
you like that that's correct gross
that's disgusting well I'm gonna say
those people are just high grass edge
esta girls and I K and the Sun we're one
I'm going to carry this box just a
lovely ladies you know I think I was
like here weird great why do I keep on I
don't know why I keep on just like
hitting the wrong trigger I keep on
hitting the right trigger oh she says I
was so silly what I did that was just so
silly
and it is a portal
so I said please terminate my client
agreement okay so weird to put on the
wall the pistol in my and now and I'm
saying I'm probably the need is though
so I don't exactly want to be drop it I
even onyx a sellout you know how about
sir and I guess the fruit is left what
happens we just don't get the food
yeah that's disgusting that use so much
crystalline how Wow
why did he die there we go do you have
to him let them die Wow now starting
that's based earth to LA huh Tejano
SAP matter wagon well be funny has one
of those um ping down here I'll click
recheck I might die
nope done anything on there
I'm just gonna just try to make it back
in I'm just trying to make it back I'm
just trying to get in my car put down
the one that maybe listen to some froggy
101 that's I'm radio you know everything
is right here hang on now
what if we drop since we run to the gap
so we just stopped and why he'll I'm why
heal can I get this perfect
I'm not really one for conversation with
this school you know nothing God Cap'n's
nothing guy hello some weight man Jesus
taking up the whole icon thank you
hi you peddling wares what if I'm going
to come across that like weird like
hunter dude
have no idea how long this game I think
it's three hours one
me of course the lion though those Rob's
I gotta tell you okay crown still like
this boys chicken feet take is that
account I got you for that see what was
but why say that Wow Wow
grain
okay nope you need to go on nikon their
price tech pistol I'm at all whatever is
mating risk it makes could be only
pistol ammo
it's pretty early that's nice yes yeah
so I thought thought oh yes stupid
critter
hate those things
they're so annoying anyway
no someone's like fishing indoor that's
crazy cut the water got that peeled so
got number house though that's the shop
I could go this way oh I guess I gotta
go that way
let's see what's let's say what's not in
here you know let's say let's not the
air hate these stupid things Jesus
a client I don't know what I was
thinking right food oh my god
man I just killed like anything human
being
shelter faith what they call themselves
Richard put a great day for a long time
you're leaving
take that you'll be seen that one
helping a half shoots over here right
turning up into my hair man 3 the
locations are like very similar but it's
like so nice looking like they did such
a good job with us like it's like pretty
diverse or being just like a side
scroller and Oh what the heck I have one
thing I wish that they had was like more
things to interact with like you can
only press like a on like two things
it's like always the same things I pick
up open door open latch then I guess so
you can money um yeah I think it's a
little too simplified yes
stupid slimeball yeah nope click on
plate is something so satisfying that I
think they had to explode on one shot I
mean it's just it is a good experience a
hello sir
yeah hey just like I don't know and I
just not yeah just not gonna have to
come with me
ideas look they just kind of a this kind
of met them up they just kind of it is
Jack I'm up you know Jesus she says you
so much mo better be worth it
put this up in here Corey half fact wow
there's a crap here it's not looking god
dad not liking good
let me struggling a little bit and I'll
just I'll bet
oh no this is the right right path oh my
god I just killed him
I'm through it oh my god she says keep
going hit when you just like open a door
and there's someone there and just have
to kill them I got real life I mean whoo
secret hello
okay but I'm still missing the guy sell
anybody he got left
this one's like babe world and I think
they just like operated the maps or
something here I did not go all the way
to the right and man Hansa pistol but
what I was you know what I realize you
need to aim back out you need to aim
anyhow family Chasez oh good that you
know it's a lie payday can you get down
there so I don't know did I miss
something
can it can nothing look nothing up
enough nothing like it should be the
right of this helmet poor fella you know
he messed with the past it's so sad
okay this where I get it right
what the heck did I miss something or
sagat's a light tank
okay right there
what the heck is going on
hmm
really not sure where it is now Kate can
ya be right around here
here we go
what the heck my god
I think that we're on a room another one
would like though the guys fishing
checked em torn using last game
okay I'm going backtracking I'm still
back dragon Shanee gasps okay
guess I'll lean up there I got my
ChaCha's hair it is empty
okay let's get out of here I think this
is the best way to go here and go all if
the right hand this one's annoying he
doesn't really look like a kid on the
cover that's bothered me too look he's
like please like balding lose a gray
endless I look like a buzz cut very
weird very weird okay
let's go let's get out of here let's
blow this everything is ready to act got
a crush I can I just stay in yeah I feel
like it whoever it takes you like help
me out
okay can you grab something
no I was up
like I was done and we answer him I just
accelerate that someone isn't iPod you
know but someone who doesn't want to
talk okay that's a great egg I look like
torque in this webcam heck is going on
here let's discuss it my boots are wet
now
[Music]
I'm an idea to make it badly made one
here
oh I have my gift okay Clermont
like that right in the lower back
strength alarm back so I'm like if they
made the levels bigger I don't like how
you have to go left out is it doesn't
loop like the first game tick was that
my phone buzz okay cry it slide
all right great what was cult people
disgusting just rally disgusting
nope not interested in writing writing a
cell boring like who'd want to write
when there's economic Pat Anna great
hate those things I'd only come so weak
again so like there's no way to just
there's no way to just like block it
it'd be nice if like your baseball bat
can block the M moves we can't nope
what I will just leave their their
laptops like Oakland without password
let's try to use that pocalypse no
wonder I must have deserved it you
stupid sucker
you know like the parallax though okay
pistol Emma got I need that banana I got
a 1/2 cat so we can live all dangerously
and now we can live a little dangerously
okay close what shopping went back store
hopefully you got to beat the task
it's a cafe okay remember if I like this
whole like continuation thing you only
to pour from the cards with you like an
hour to get back his calling is like
plays I like house easy okay I got all
see if there's anything head brow they
just plain out the last year days that
now let's just get back out of here yeah
we spent way Todd's time in this dump
town what about the ladies anywhere a
house so he this thing at the walkway
back the last game was like so nice you
own one way and then they have like
another way back which was different so
you weren't even like wasting your time
this one is just like it's like good
luck solitaire like let's make this a
walking simulator like the last one
didn't walk as a watch I I can't like
talking it's good for your heart healthy
and a like let's just walk more and
that's what they did you know that's
what they did okay come on come on come
on just kind of just walk in walk a dog
in my guy's car I can't take one on a is
this is watch guy with the mandolin yeah
calm down with the man let's get louder
ding-ding-ding-ding-ding okay and less
my car's my shoes are getting wet and I
kinda my shares are getting wet again
you know how hard it is to find Prada
boots and their block ellipse today this
okay it's a real buzz hell [ __ ]
exhausted time - yeah I'll be
accompanying heroes fighting the zombies
this
how that I go that's great it's kind of
a
really much going on goes game now so
mechanics are better but they should
have just took the mechanics put in the
first game like ray hauled it did a
remaster into the DLC okay there can be
service I'm gonna jobs of that tank is
this like cheery world hello sir can I
help you don't forget no lemma trick
there you live if you miss one you won't
get paid a huge drink wait can I go up
no okay
finally I like when there's some closure
I like a little linear game Long's kind
of like not really that obvious linear
yes stupid animal sty down nobody knows
okay make us count little a there we go
it's got left now till Tomatoes stupid
critter stupid goat beds still bed there
we go come on let's get out of here all
right
hello son you're working today what is
the point of these like survivors crafts
and crafting will it work better
it'll take him ow
oh you can back that away ooh you go
like 10 bolts that guy sees this I can't
see any gas okay let's blow that shine
let's call that moisted areas i found
the gas cannon right away okay I wasn't
fooled by all this Venus on out I didn't
want a bit there what would it be in a
sawmill so stupid
okay let's go let's get out of here like
his eyes are still open so he can look
at me walk away you know down take out
your heart it's just a tick about water
it's kind of tough because like
selecting of this I did not get any
crafting utility so I couldn't make any
help kids but I'll probably lose some
health trying to get the health kits
even if I didn't why would I even bother
getting health kits if I don't lose help
let you know it doesn't make any sense
okay like psychobabble is all about
sense I hope there are some survivors I
really can't take one here you fold up
your thing stupid dang stupid critter
getting here no place ready like
ransacked
can we look in there
yes a I skip that all tight and cases
phone no of course not
snow in a call talu bra just to lame out
point less yeah like that
perfect now you just got to pop those
suckers pop them like the pills you know
anyone want to take me here because I
got to raise out the Kalou
pick up in here and doctor is like this
place is industrialized us act like a
place cuddle in here tell us our atom I
why don't you say that I mean business
not you saying that now I loaded and
packed and caring your atom traitor
weight into the hunter no she's not
wearing those so this is a hunter so
it's a damage the crystal that was part
of the sales Anna
he's going to count so he's an alien
this hunter set out Doran
do I not say me open the door he's like
facing me
what the heck say I said I want to talk
to him getting scheduled cancel cancel
meet something gasps Elena okay so I am
going to meet this guy later that's good
news and I wore at the pit with him and
anything gasping though you know here's
the way maybe I'm just kind of a now
gasps Kevin sighs down there Josh I see
have to go left the car I think so noise
someone's walking this one those guys
can't just go check out here you know
any of apocalypse
you can't be you can't be going on sites
for the town you got to get to once you
get your stuff you got to move on ashes
why don't you want me to come out with
you too I never said your tenant 32
minutes I think we hit like three or
four to remember I'm just saying very
efficient I'm just being very efficient
close F
oh okay why not have any money
Oh your money shut up I don't get it
what's with the red eyes though I
supposed to be like a ball
listen I forgot to tell you and then
they drive off places like heavily
industrial think it's like they've got
to be like the feature but the gums are
so weak you know okay finally come on
going away yeah here dog okay cat stupid
hey president left so it's a prison area
see that
what is that pistol I'm marketing yeah
yeah that song sounds like turning pages
public hate that thing I'll take that
1200 so must be the lighthouse that we
passed interesting now that knows the
lighthouse prison how this hell blocks
however found anything yet
workshop torture so I'll be used anymore
Fernand okay well I just carried a
toilet until like a dark style so that's
a quite left decision like those people
down there waiting yeah many items yet
oh Jesus I know those things like get
jacked up too
yes there's a critter look at this thing
okay wait take a left is that water
all right look I can't go left Jesus
this one can be huge hate when there's
too many choices
okay all right broken
okay this implies a la bete manic we see
that good the heck is this and I got to
get to that prison I wrote our necessary
locked basement nut bran we need ammo
okay so there's there's ammo down there
perfect
stupid thing McConnell's dead
and he didn't leave she says they have
deleted she says where the heck are the
key Grodd ate the cane a decay it's kind
of a pair right Harris
boss is gone okay the first one has
loading total death so much is here
smoking now
well a lot of ammo okay what do I still
need basically everything what is that
like I need water and gas
right like that
yeah well
okay a lot of crappy homes though I
can't hide after this I'm so down here I
hate that thing
okay oh god I hate these things
nope and I went in here no okay I'll sit
here see here and he still needs so much
if I get through the car
yeah all right no oh my god just one is
huge okay let's focus I got babble
socket there's a thing right there have
a water in the bunker rent or gas line
all right now don't pit me
wow this is like an actual serious
bunker she's I hate those better okay
see I'm here I'll take out the water
conscious gasoline that's how that it
and that name is let gasoline and I
don't have so much my desk I okay how do
I get to my car as I'm driving around
gas line
okay he left below that
maybe this'll take me to my car yeah
okay we're going to end this here house
a long level to thank you thanks a lot
said yeah thank ya